welcome to this video out corny I corner
ok I have played the sky before yes four
out of five that's that sounds good
let's just do something that I know for
change the good wood google indian maybe
like this not a five again check I wait
he might take with the night never know
then I really don't Wow is this more I
wasn't even know where that this is
possible okay yeah yeah I guess 94 must
be right in any case but I didn't ever I
never ever saw define a disposition
yeah Jack gets the checkya he might play
93 what exactly is my move then this is
not not that much of a problem who the
fibers a strange a move we had will you
yet yeah that's not exactly a refutation
i mean i don't think i have any any
problem really but hmm no idea md5 is
sam i move that I that I don't know at
all okay or i do my t5 here and I'd be
fine i can and i can really just move
the king king is not that not that badly
placed anyway on the near the Queen side
something like Bishop d7 or a six and
then C porn moved for King c7 after ship
d7 is a bit of a zero move yet I cannot
probably not take well control of plate
should have played a six-minute would
have been better Cameron's let's kick
this back
okay it's kinda weird but not a problem
really I want to prepare bouquet evade
and night GF 6 yeah Bishop d7 was a
stupid move I should play a 6
immediately yeah route kf8 I guess to
get rid of one pair of rooks then I can
go from them check is a nice advantage
in space I will regroup the knight to f6
so that it takes you for that's probably
the best best square maybe I could have
played a five now that I think of it but
for once I playing quickly so let's
stick with this this attitude
yeah white can I don't know if he can
really do that much okay mostly yeah sit
tight a4 a5 is something that is
strategically desirable that not sure if
you can do it
i wonder if i should play a five really
maybe yeah no it's not i can take with
the king yeah it's maybe not that a bad
idea something like a three is
definitely helping me and if he takes d6
i can i can take what the king of really
as possible that's interesting the night
is coming to see for via a three-year
this is what i have not what I have
underestimated yeah okay it's not not
terrible I all via this this route also
also a possible of course ok need to
kick this back yeah 98 he has night see
for King f6 rook everyone okay
it's not easy not easy afternoon after
night here I can take the five so that's
not a good pollution ready
as preventing a force is going for it
anyway I will take b6 ah after Bishop b5
he will take p6 ok it's no no way around
that anymore wow really really bad chest
I mean what did i do here I mean it
wasn't that bad really I was I didn't
have a great position I'm really not
telling telling telling you any nonsense
I mean not not claiming i was in great
shape but i didn't really need to go
down like that that is just so easier
now that I think of it I can take 94
take edge to what yeah maybe get lost in
any case pretty much does not matter
what I do check check and with his help
and we cried a lot here by allowing all
those checks ok so I have to walk over
I'm sure why you would put it on a light
scram
time warning 190s 96 maybe first I'm
running on time and I only now see that
really yeah white foreheads five times
they are no idea that he was very slow
somehow job what what what did I do
wrong I mean I really should be in and
okay in an ok situated situation here
nothing great or what but but I should
be ok but maybe I really didn't think
that this is so great but he gets this
Knight to c4 yeah that's a huge problem
that's really a huge problem down here
i'm just in bad shape I have no way
really to to keep that to keep this
together in some way yeah I saw knight
Knight b6 but I'm just lost anyway yeah
and here he is winning her in check that
means that i cannot really do what i did
here if I'm it and I cannot play a five
then this is what what stock fishes
suggestion suggesting
yeah I thought that this should be a bit
better for wide at least at least a bit
better hmm yeah well I don't know that
was lucky in any case okay thanks for
watching